-Hello, I'm Aimee Lou Wood.
-My name is Chinenye Ezeudu.
-I'm George Robinson.
-I'm Chaneil Kular.
And we're going to teach you
how to act...
And it's free. Free.
Most drunk people
do not want to appear drunk,
so it's like
when you're really drunk,
you try to convince everyone
that you're sober.
So you play
that you're absolutely fine,
like, yo, I'm fine.
I'm fine! I'm fine!
-And release.
-I think you should go.
-I live here.
-I don't care.
Well, you know what?
Half of it is done for you.
If fact, I'd probably say
90% is done for you.
What's happened
to your face?
Prosthetics on your face.
That helps a lot, really,
with the swelling.
We call that "corpsing",
don't we?
Though,
to corpse is to laugh.
Someone taught me a trick.
You bite your tongue,
like, you bite somewhere
in your mouth.
And it never works.
We had one
on the last day of filming
season 3.
Ben came in
with an idea for the scene.
He whispered it in my ear
and it was
the funniest thing.
When the scene was going on,
I knew it was coming,
and I knew
that Emma didn't know
what was gonna happen
and I said it
and Emma just cracked up.
And I just cracked up
and honestly Ben
was cracking up,
it took us so long
to just get
this one line out.
Who's this?
Maeve, that's Steve.
No, Aimee, the goat.
Think in the scenes,
it was really emotional.
You just are there
and your body
kind of reacts to....
what you're saying
and you just feel it
or just think of-- Yeah.
Like memories
might help the scene
if you're really struggling.
Making playlists
for your characters
and making playlists
for different--
is so helpful
'cause music
is the most evocative,
like it just, yeah.
It just hits your soul
so quickly and easily.
From the wonderful
intimacy coordinators
on set, that, you know,
these scenes
have been spoken about
a lot of time in advance.
Make sure, like you said,
everyone's in a safe space
and feels protected
in like an area
where you can play
and do whatever
you kind of have to do.
-Strawberry flavoured.
-I love berries.
The truth is,
I did not handle that goat.
She handled you.
She handled me.
Oh, completely!
Never once did I scare
or guide that goat.
So it made everything
take so much longer
because they were, like,
Aimee you've kind of
got to be assertive
and walk out
and the goat will follow.
What is happening?
Tell me now!
Why are you naked?
I mean,
Ruby's always in the middle.
And, I dunno,
we're kind of
Ruby's sidekicks a bit,
so it kind of just works.
Like, she runs down
the middle
and we're just
little sightings with it.
It's true.
So, there was some times
that we were on
an actual moving bus.
That was the actual bus,
but most of this stuff
is filmed like
with green screen.
And then there were just
a lot of men
on either side of the bus
pushing the bus
back and forth,
so that was the real motion
that we were doing.
Anne Harrod, our first AD,
she would shout...
And then we'd go...
is everyone okay?
I get someone else
to do them.
And then I take credit
for them on screen.
How have you done that?
-You never.
-Hm-mmm.
Well, you're very talented.
You've even captured
her angry eyebrows.
Aimee and Viv,
were talking about acting.
That was Acting Class
with Aimee and Viv.
Well, I think that's
gonna be really useful
-for everyone, really.
-Yeah, I agree.
And watch season 3
of Sex Education
now on Netflix.